m
on
je hais
voici à quoi ressemble une compétition
d'aviron indoor
les rameurs les humains sont alignées
comme s'ils étaient sur l'eau mais il
chevauche des ergomètres le nom de ces
machines que l'on voit généralement dans
les salles dédiées à la remise en forme
ici on les utilise comme des bateaux
avec l'iphone danse individuelle sur
c'est une course à la taille
dassault avec les bâtons donc chaque
personne
du coup
à essence dans son ensemble il y a donc
des courses individuelles et aussi des
relais comme ceux 10000 mètres une
distance réservée à des jeunes gens en
excellente condition physique car le
corps et surtout le coeur sans soumis à
très rude épreuve le rythme cardiaque il
monte à combien il est encore là donc
c'est bon ça allait vraiment bien on
s'entraîne sur ces machines ont des pubs
sa force et
on développe aussi un peu le le cardio
et sa s'entraîne aussi s'entraîne aussi
pour les bras conditions de course
c'est une pratique incontournable dans
la préparation hivernale des rameurs il
y a d'ailleurs un championnat du monde
prévu à paris les 7 et 8 février
prochains
mais certains ne sont pas encore prêts